-My first guest is an Emmy and
Golden Globe-winning actor
who stars in the new movie
"No Sudden Move,"
which comes to HBO Max July 1st,
please welcome Jon Hamm,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ Jon Hamm ♪
♪ Mad man ♪
♪ When it's time to be Sergio,
he's a sax man ♪
♪ Jon Hamm ♪
♪ Big fan ♪
♪ Of the hockey team
St. Louis Blues ♪
♪ That's his jam ♪
♪ Jon Hamm ♪
♪ Mad man ♪
♪ When it's time to be Sergio,
he's a sax man ♪
♪ Haaaam ♪
♪♪
-Thank you for coming.
-Does this feel good or what?
-That's what I'm talking about.
This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I missed it. But thank you.
You were nice enough
to do our show
when I was doing it
from my home.
-Which was fun.
This is more fun.
-Yeah.
-Or funnest.
-Yeah, it is.
This is the funnest.
-I like nothing more
than a callback.
-Hey, I heard a rumor about you.
You may be filming a movie.
-Yes. I'm filming a movie.
-You are, but are you doing --
-Well, I'll tell you.
Maybe you can guess
what I'm filming.
It starts with an "F."
-Yes.
-And it rhymes with "fletch."
-[ Laughs ]
-You are doing "Fletch?"
-We're remaking "Fletch," yes.
We're rebooting Fletch
up in Boston.
We start Monday
and we're very excited.
Greg Mottola is directing.
Myself, John Slattery...
-Holy moly.
-A cast of others will be in it.
-That's major!
-Very exciting. Very exciting.
-That's genius!
-Yes. Very, very exciting.
It's very exciting.
We all loved the movie
growing up.
It's an '80s staple, and we're
gonna sort of reboot it
and update it for the 2000s.
-You're perfect.
-Well, thank you.
-I was going to talk about
"Top Gun: Maverick," of course.
-Oh, we can talk about that,
too.
-Yeah. I mean...
I'm so excited. You've got
some big movies right now.
But "Top Gun: Maverick."
-Well, I think I'm just gonna
go through the '80s
and try to be in all of either
the sequels or the reboots
of all of those.
-That's smart.
-Keep your eyes out
for "Labyrinth."
-Wow, that'll be fantastic.
Did you bond with Tom Cruise?
-T.C.? Yes, I did.
-T.C. Wow. They call him T.C.?
-Yeah, well, you know.
-Wow.
-Once you know him,
he's kind of...
No, I had actually met Tom
a long time before.
I was a friend's --
Jimmy Kimmel's house.
Another Jimmy.
-He has fun parties.
-He has fun parties, and he was
having a football-watching party
of a Sunday, as you do.
And the rumor got around,
"Somebody said
Tom Cruise was coming today."
And everyone was like,
"No, he's not."
It's like,
it's a football party.
We're all watching football.
It's like, a bunch of idiots
eating pizza and drinking beer.
Tom Cruise is not coming
to this football party.
Cut to three minutes later,
Tom Cruise walks in
with his mom.
-What?
-Mom Cruise.
-Mom Cruise. Oh, my gosh!
I didn't even think of that.
Dude, that's genius.
Did you start that?
Mom Cruise is the best.
-And then cut to
the reverse of this, like,
40 dudes just with
their jaws on the ground like,
"Is this actually happening?"
So I did bring that up
when I --
He said, "Yeah, that was
a fun party, man.
We had a great time. Me and my
mom, that was awesome."
-I was like, "You remembered
that. Okay, well."
It was clearly more important
to me than you, but...
-How was Mom Cruise?
-Excellent. She can hang.
-And just cool, right?
-Yeah. She can hang.
-I love that. That's fantastic.
-It was a fun, fun time,
and Tom is the most
giving, wonderful guy.
He's the first guy
and the last guy out.
He's the hardest-working guy
on the set.
He's always in a good mood.
He's got all
the heavy lifting to do,
including, like, flying planes
at Mach-whatever.
And, you know,
it's inspirational.
I'll tell you that much.
-Let's talk about
"No Sudden Move."
-Let's do.
-This is a heist movie.
-Yes.
-I don't want to
give too much away,
but that's the thing now,
with the...
-I didn't do it.
[ Audience laughs ]
-You can't say that.
-Well, no, there's a lot of
other people in the movie.
-That's not even in question.
-Wasn't me.
-Shaggy's in the movie.
-The rapper or
the cartoon character?
-[ Laughing ] Both.
-[ As Shaggy ] Oh, no, Scoob!
We're in a heist movie
directed by Steven Soderbergh!
[ As Scooby-Doo ] Rokey-doke!
-Dude, Steven Soderbergh.
Come on.
-Cartoon character is
the obvious answer.
-This is great,
when you do impressions.
But what's it like getting
directed by Steven Soderbergh?
-Well, first of all, we shot
this movie in October,
so it was in
the middle of the pandemic.
We shot it in Detroit. The movie
takes place in the '50s.
So it's a period film that
has a lot of moving parts,
a lot of cars,
a lot of costumes,
a lot of hair and makeup.
Everything that you
wouldn't want to do
in the middle of a pandemic,
and Steven Soderbergh
was like a conductor.
He just, nothing fazed him.
He had this very, very
complicated story
with all these moving parts.
We would finish in 6-hour days.
Nobody got sick.
We stayed in a bubble.
Everybody stayed
in the same hotel.
That was very fun, so we all
got to kind of hang out.
It was a lovely, lovely
experience,
and we made a really wonderful
movie with an amazing cast.
-Benicio del Toro.
-Benicio del Toro,
Don Cheadle, Ray Liotta.
-Don Cheadle!
-Myself and people like me.
-David Harbour. Yeah. Exactly.
-Harbour.
-David Harbour.
I want to show a clip here.
It is Jon Hamm and David Harbour
in "No Sudden Move."
Take a look at this.
-Mr. Wertz.
Detective Joe Finney.
Michigan State
Attorney General's office.
Organized crime task force.
-Organized crime?
-Yeah. Uh...
Detroit police
got two phone calls.
One from a friend,
Mrs. Atkinson,
said she was concerned,
and then another from a neighbor
said they heard loud noises.
-Organized crime, like the mob?
-Well, I guess that's
the $6,400 question, isn't it?
♪♪
-Woo!
-See?
-Subtle!
-Yes, I love that!
Jon Hamm, everybody!
-Subtle!